I like micro failure I like micro
failure
I hate macro failure like death of your
business is bad but it wasn't as though
in creating these companies that we
thought that we would be successful I
thought that the most likely outcome was
failure we don't have enough time for me
to list all of our failed experiments
but the big winners pay for thousands of
failed experiments wanna be happy build
a life not just the business
hates every Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you two
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
succeed despite failures okay let's kick
it off with rule number one don't let
failure stop you tell us about failure
and why it's important to I love it yeah
cuz you I love it I like micro failure
I like micro failure I hate macro
failure like death of your business is
bad but but to me you know what's funny
I'll use a boxing analogy my favorite
boxing but I watch a lot of boxing
I think box things are very interesting
and I know and I'm super into mixed
martial arts but I grew up on boxing I
understand it better and I like watching
it because there's so many things that
happen in boxing first of all what I
love about boxing is there's nowhere to
hide you know like it's super
interesting right there's nowhere to
hide
number two there's something there's a
scenario boxing that I love the most
there's for some reason there's nothing
more interesting to me than watching
somebody get knocked down in the first
round and then go on to win the fight
easily it's an interesting psyche right
and I like that and this is what I'm
thinking about it which is like here's
what's bad in boxing and in business
going into a fight getting knocked the
[ __ ] out in the first round and losing
the match bad getting knocked down and
then having the adversity to readjust to
what you got caught on and navigating it
too easily when a fight is remarkable
that's how I think about
entrepreneurship people the reason so
many people struggle with
entrepreneurship is you have micro
failures almost daily and they're very
in-your-face you can't hide and I like
that I like failure I because I think I
deserve it I hate when people don't
respect the game when I fail it means I
thought
and I like that because I think people
get audacious my number one thing that I
hate about capitalism is that people use
it and they love it and they're big
capitalists and they love open market
and competition and all that and then
they become 73 and they try to use all
their money to protect their money
they're not willing to let a young lion
eat them the way they ate somebody else
I hate when they try to manipulate it
that's what I love about sports what I
love about sports is when you're 36 and
you were once the best player in the
league but now you're getting a little
bit older and your body breaks down you
are forced to retire the one thing that
entrepreneurship and capitalism has to
adjust to is once you get old and you're
tired and you want to be on a yacht
instead of working you're you should
lose some money because you're losing
rule number two don't be afraid to fail
with Jeff Bezos by the way getting it
wrong isn't that bad that's the other
thing when when we make mistakes and
we've made Dizzy's like the fire phone
and many other things that just didn't
work out I can I could look we don't
have enough time for me to list all of
our failed experiments but the big
winners pay for thousands of failed
experiments so you try something like
prime and it was very expensive at the
beginning it cost us a lot of money
because what happens when you offer a
free all-you-can-eat buffet who shows up
to the buffet first the heavy eaters
it's scary it's like oh my god did I
really say it's many prawns as you can
eat
and and so that is what happened but but
surely we could see the trend lines we
could see that you know the different
all kinds of customers were coming and
they appreciated that service also if
you want to have more motivation and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links join our new
description below my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur like I
would never take a note like that scares
the piss out of me what these three
people are doing right now from day one
I just I never tried to hide that I was
the girl in my apartment with the red
backpack I was reminded this morning no
big question I'm often asked how do you
eliminate fear from your life rule
number three don't fear failure with
Elon Musk we got to try to create an
electric car company but it wasn't as
though in creating these companies that
we thought that we would be successful I
thought that the most likely outcome was
failure but but it was still worth doing
even though the odds of success were low
in fact in full force poor SpaceX the
originally what I started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was gonna do a small mission to
Mars which was just a philanthropic
mission where we would send a small
green house with seeds and dehydrator
gel in the gourd upon landing hydrate
the gel and you'd have this cool picture
of green plants on a red background and
the public tends to respond to
precedents and superlative so this will
be the first lap on Mars where this that
life's ever traveled and you have this
great money shot of green plants on the
right background and so I thought that
would get people's attention so but but
the expectation for that was was no
return I thought we wouldn't get any you
know we'll just spend the money on that
and it wouldn't wouldn't happen rule
number four redefine failure with Sara
Blakely growing up my father used to ask
my brother and me what we had failed at
at the dinner table which was so
interesting and he'd celebrate it and
he'd actually be disappointed if I
didn't have something that I failed at
that week so I can remember saying dad
dad I tried out for this and I was home
and he would actually high-five me and
say congratulations way to go and what
it did was just reframe my desh
definition of failure failure for me
became not trying versus the outcome so
so many people don't take risks for fear
of failure they don't start the business
they don't go create the art they want
to create or they don't go try out to be
in the play or whatever it is for the
fear of failure and once you redefine
that for yourself and realize the
failure is just not trying then life
opens up to you in many ways and I would
also my dad would encourage me anytime
something didn't go the way I expected
it to or maybe I got embarrassed by a
situation to write down where the hidden
gifts were and what I got out of it and
I started realizing and everything there
was some amazing nugget that I wouldn't
have wanted to pass up and rule number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is seek failures with Bob
Proctor you should seek failures see if
you're playing it safe you're not gonna
win if you're playing it safe like that
all say you know you're topping your
little girl better to be safe than sorry
well that's a bunch of crap it's not
better be safe than sorry it's by trying
things that you figure out how far you
can go you've got to get outside the box
like it's reported Edison tried 3000
ways before he built incandescent light
he said he didn't deal 3000 times he
said there was 3000 different steps to
building a light bulb well there's
different steps to get to where you're
going and I really do treat winning and
losing exactly the same I do not let it
upset me do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful well it's
part of why I enjoy it yeah I think it
is because I'll try anything like if if
I'm into an idea the idea of losing
never enters my mind see I have worked
with giants I had the good fortune of
working with Sir Edmund Hillary he was
the first man to stand
on top of the world and I worked with
him on three different occasions and the
only difference in ed Hillary and Bob
Proctor is in his his size now he's gone
now but he was a big man when he shook
hands with me his hand wrap right around
mine I felt like Oh
dwarf you know and and talked into him
like it never entered his mind he
wouldn't get to the top of the mountain
but he failed in 1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain
no people had died for centuries trying
to do that he said I knew if I could see
it in here I could hold it out here
still a man wrote that in the book he
could seat in your head you can hold it
in your hand and that's right
and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never gonna win because you're
always playing it safe and there's no
there's no reward in that now I have a
special bonus tip from Lisa Nichols on
how to give yourself permission to fail
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that is sent for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go
question number one what is one thing
you want to try but you're afraid of
failing number two what's one small step
you could take today to start building
momentum and number three who can you
commit to to make sure that you follow
through every day and if you like this
video and promise you take action after
watching it give me a hash tag believe
down in the comments as well we don't
just watch videos here we do something
about it so give me a hash tag believe
make that promise to yourself and then
get to work so often you don't move
forward because you're keeping such
score from what didn't work in the past
you are holding yourself hostage to 1997
to 2005 you're holding yourself hostage
in love to that past relationship that
didn't work or you're holding yourself
in hostage in business to the money that
you may have thought you wasted or the
deal that went bad and so one of the
ways that I give myself permission
for two on two levels permission to have
lived a life that has some beautiful
experiences and some really tangy
lessons I mean they're spicy they hurt
they're painful when I give myself
permission to have had that I also give
myself permission to keep leaping give
myself permission to keep dreaming give
myself permission to keep learning how
to get it right learning how to love the
unlovable forgive what seems to be the
unforgivable to leap again even while I
still have a bandage on my chin from the
last time I fell I still get to lead
someone invite you if you fall fall
catch your breath
put a bandage on it whether you fail
financially you fail physically with
health and wellness you feel spiritually
you felt emotionally you felt in a
relationship okay a part of flying is
understanding what the distinction
between flying and falling and the only
way you understand the distinction is
that you experience full life when you
experience full life it's like this life
isn't just flatline is not just like
this you make your Heights feel better
because you understand this was a
failure and and what I mean by a failure
is this taught me a lesson this stung
this every single failure has a lesson
in it to me a failure is a lesson
wrapped in some sticky icky paper that
stung that hurt and so give yourself
permission give yourself permission to
play big to be nervous to fall down to
sit down for a minute just don't take up
real estate in the sitting down don't
take up real estate in the analyzing
don't take some don't take up real
estate in the preparation you've been
getting prepared for a long time for
something trust that you'll either fly
if you leap right now or you're fall if
you leave right now and if you fly
you'll understand what soaring feels
like and if you fall you'll understand
what getting up feels like either way
you're okay
that's how I play big with my knees
knocking that's how I play big even when
there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time I did something like this and it
didn't quite work out and I still play
big because I gave myself I give myself
I constantly give myself permission to
totally win and soar are totally falling
it up and that way there's nothing to
truly be afraid of remember this is a
dialogue not a monologue which means
we're in a dynamic conversation versus
me just entertaining you
and if you want to learn how to activate
your lying mode checking the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there so think about why say suffering
people cringe people that thought that's
the one word whenever I post about it
people cringe nothing happening run mode